so we knew that at some point kyle
rittenhouse riding high on the heroism
of his not guilty verdict as per the
right
uh after he killed uh a couple of people
would somehow come back and be used by
the right in some way that maybe he
would understand and maybe he would not
understand but he was going to become a
tool of the right at least until his
celebrity sort of runs out it already
may be running out actually because he
has now started an organization that no
one seems to care about and he barely
seems to even understand what it is
about so we're gonna look at a clip and
you almost start to feel bad for the kid
because he's just getting used he
doesn't know what's going on he doesn't
know you know down from up and day from
night newsweek reports kyle rittenhouse
launches a fund to finance lawsuits
targeting media lies
even that is more coherent than how
rittenhouse explained it to tucker
carlson uh uh on on his program which
we're gonna get to in a moment
um
this is a new donation fund where you
can donate
and then they will hold accountable
media outlets and individuals it's
called the media accountability project
and i guess what it will be used to do
is to finance lawsuits now i'm gonna
play for you the
uh i'm gonna play for you a clip of kyle
rittenhouse being interviewed by tucker
carlson on on monday night
and rittenhouse seems to have no idea
what's going on i mean just absolutely
no clue what this even is at one point
he nervously drinks water and looks off
camera he seems confused
and tucker carlson is like trying to
help him almost explain what it is that
he's doing and so
we can come to only a couple of
conclusions one of which is
he has no idea what they're doing
uh or number two he's in way over his
head all right let's take a look for
kyle thanks so much for coming on
tonight i can't think of many people
who've been at the receiving end of this
much sinister lying from so-called news
organizations right because you have
how are you going to respond
well tucker thank you for having me um
of course me and my team have decided to
by the way he has a team now that's
that's even i would love to know who who
is on his team that's advising him
launched the media accountability
project as a tool to help fundraise and
hold the media accountable for the lies
they said and deal with them in court
wow kyle that's really something
tell us more please
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be and if you're watching you
just saw him
in a panicked way look off camera okay
suing news organizations that
maliciously lie about people who are in
the news right is that the plan
yes sir we're going to be holding them
accountable tucker
do you
he has no idea what he's doing and you
know we're laughing at it because it's
so it's impossible you know to avoid
laughing
but we really should almost like feel
bad that now he's clearly being taken
advantage of and it's not even clear
whether if you donate money to this
media accountability project tmap the
media accountability project it's not
even clear the money really will be used
for lawsuits i mean remember this is a
very common right-wing grift
which is trump did it after the 2020
election trump said hey
this we i need your help
i need you to donate i need you to
donate so that we can fund recounts
and legal challenges
and flip some states and if you looked
at the fine print
at least half the money was not even
potentially going to be used for that
and of course they didn't do the
recounts they didn't do any of it you
you just you gave mon trump money and
trump did what he wanted with the money
and it very well could be a similar
thing here but in terms of written house
clearly being taken advantage of he
doesn't have any idea what they're doing
he doesn't know how they're going to be
doing it
he doesn't know
how any of this stuff works
and i am not
ignoring the irony
that
fox here tucker is promoting tucker by
bringing on kyle
is promoting someone who who says i want
to hold the media accountable for lying
when it is fox news that for over a year
has welcomed liars about the 2020
election
and covid and vaccines it is fox news
who arguably should be held accountable
and that irony
i mean it's not that it's lost on tucker
it's just completely missing even from
any
notion of a consideration that he might
have and so uh this is the latest scam
and kyle rittenhouse at the end of the
day is probably being used i don't think
he knows what's going on you know the
wright loves to say biden doesn't have
any idea what's going on he doesn't know
what he's doing he doesn't know what
he's actually signing
kyle rittenhouse has no clue what this
is about and uh if you were actually
subjected to real questioning here it
would get very bad and at the end of the
day he's basically a kid i guess legally
he's an adult now i think now he's 18.
but this is basically a clueless kid
being uh lionized because he got away
with killing a couple people
and
now is being used even further to try to
push the goals that he barely
understands of people who are using his
what i think is going to be ultimately
short-lived fame
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries i've been
watching curiosity stream at home for
over a year now really no better place
to find the newest and best
documentaries curiosity stream selection
is way better than any other platform i
recently watched the documentary return
of the buffalo a fascinating animal and
fascinating things to know about
conservation of the buffalo as well
curiosity stream adds new titles every
month you're never going to run out of
great documentary content you can learn
something new zone out on a nature
documentary whatever you're looking for
they have it if you love documentaries
you are missing out if you don't have
curiosity stream it's super affordable
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off which means you can get it for 15
bucks a year
go to curiositystream.com
pacman the link is underneath this video